hey folks please enjoy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
Rifts as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so come check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m. Eastern
you stupid
idiots M what's a classic karaoke song
Sweet Caroline like I said that's a good
one uh Don't Stop Believing Don't Stop
Believing it's Piano Man piano man piano
man is another one I don't know any of
the newer ones okay uh if you did if you
answered the Mars VTA in the chat you're
right first of all what first of all
first of all
this isn't in a real karaoke place right
no this is in his house okay cuz I was
going to say how what karaoke guy has
Mars Vault nobody hon Honestly though
think about it this would be a brilliant
bit if you filmed yourself yeah going up
to karaoke DJs and being like hey you
got any at to drive in they're like what
yeah you know you don't have any of that
do you do you guys know who Mars VTA is
yeah of course I know Mars VTA is yeah
okay I they [__] you mean you mean 12
minute [__] self-indulgent guitar
solo F [__] songs yeah I've heard of
them yeah hey you want to hear all the
time signatures all on top of each other
all at once and in Spanish well if I got
the band for you I I want to go to
karaoke DJs and be like you got any
Dream
Theater do you have the wreck of the S
with fitgerald
like no it's already it's going to be
last call in 10 minutes no do you have
do you have do you have in
a you got any
opth oh
[__] you got black dog from Steven
Wilson do you have any Mike chot solo
stuff yeah yeah any any of that Fort
Minor yeah stuff for what's the name Min
for Miner Miner my God I forgot that was
a thing oh [__] okay you know what you
know what it's fine just any Coheed in
camri just throw it up I got you
whatever one you got I know you got
plenty I'll riff I'll just riff with
that whichever one I could do all of
them yeah I could do all of them what's
that really what hey V what's that
really abstract brand new album the one
that you always mention oh [__] Daisy
yeah you got anything off Daisy got
anything off a daisy by brand new no sir
this is a bar we're having fun do you
have I want to do that Andre 2000 that
new flute song do you have that just the
I've brought I brought I brought my own
mer like one of those guys with the pool
sticks and he's putting his flute
together they think I'm here to play
pool and all of a sudden it's a
flute I got this 200 bucks of Guitar
Center it was used some seventh grader
had it performance sister Charlie goes
do you have any Jimmy world
yes so I'm going to do 212 from
Rush oh
[__] God damn okay do you have any B
sides from a perfect circle
[Laughter]
I want to really depress this crowd no
Virgie what was that third like what was
that third band that that he had not
tool not perfect circle the funny one oh
God [__] you know what I'm talking about
right yeah it was like one of those
[__] just some in the they pretended
to be like a country a country
group yeah [__] when mayor just got
bored as [__] he like I'm tired I hate
mat by the way I hate I I hate tul I
want to sing I want to sing like I don't
like tul either not a big fan I want to
sing I want to sing lost profits at a
[__] karaoke bar and just but open it
by going like hey guys before I sing
this I just want to say you know I hate
what the guy did but this this is a
banger and then sing last train
home Jesus
Christ look not forgiving what he did
just everybody all mad at me it's my
first time doing this song and a one and
a
two and a one and the
two I'm going to do Gary Glitter rock
and roll part one that's what I'm doing
there we go which stupid famous PTO
songs mhm well throw a little bowi in
there part two was about Thailand that's
the thing too you could be like oh right
so I can sing David Bowie but I can't
sing lost profits that's pretty that's
pretty [__] oh I could sing MC
Jagger but not lost profets
St Tyler adopted a 16-year-old girl so
he could legally marry her that happened
so Cat Cat Scratch Fever is fine put l
offes out F yeah I can think that n it's
fine about saw when he got community
noted Ted n got community noted because
he was doing the whole re you know the
whole Reich grifter thing like oh yeah
they were all a bunch of groomers and
Community notes came gave the whole
[__] breakdown in t new's
relationship with that girl it was very
funny
oh sorry Dayton we we went off on a
tangent there oh [__] all right Mars VTA
Dayton hypernova for those who know who
Dayton hypernova is I highly
recommend okay well that's broad Strokes
just helping those are broad strokes but
I was going to say you know what you
don't want to search in Rumble Revenge
of the CIS [__] you get Lindy Graham
videos I mean you get a lot of videos
you'll get the wrong
neighborhood it's the first thing that
pops up you get every generic episode
where we're just calling each other that
yeah we get bored sometimes which is a
lot more than you think uh anyway what
was I saying oh yeah
um if you search for Avenger that says
date and hypernova and you know you know
what we got now we can make playlist on
Rumble I'm going to try because we have
a a date and hypernova playlist on our
RC clip Channel on YouTube so you go to
YouTube right now the playlist is made
there and every time a Dayton made a new
video we have a super cut from beginning
to end but basically he's this trans
person
that
uh God how do you explain Dan hyper NOA
they have to they have to just there's
no way to do it he's lived with his
parents forever he's got uh that
psoriasis he's a [__] [__] weirdo
he accused his brother who's dead now
may he rest in peace of beating him in
his house for being trans he broke a
wine glass over his brother's head
during you know how I think we could
introduce Dayton Play the song which one
good point pessy well you would have to
send it to me again because okay I have
to find it all right I got you yeah no I
actually you know what I should be able
to to find it because uh let me see here
uh what a joy of pessy
Dayton it's going to try to correct it
to Pepsi like it normally
does uh let's see here I don't know that
he private he might have he might have
he might have uh no did you mean Pepsi
no I did not mean Pepsi God damn it
pessy you firstam for SEO you really
[__] up with your
name uh let's see here uh I can't
comment on that topic I have two y's in
my name for no reason yeah well that's
cuz you're terrible at everything you do
yeah you don't believe me look at the
comments of the episodes so Pepsi's
entire audience is just illiterate
people who Googled Pepsi yeah but that's
pretty much our audience too so I'm not
really trying to pick on him you know
what I
mean
I send me the he beats me song boom
there you go I sent it to him he'll He
he'll get it to me all
right you're going to hate him
immediately all right I'm about to sing
along well I'm yeah he wears women's
clothing too but he still dates women
I'm going to sing to Mars vulta song
iara it's not a single long they're not
even putting the he is [__] up again
huh yeah the pills the pills and pills
and is really getting more and more
[__] up as time goes on go it so I'm
just doing this as best I can to the
karaoke of it and there are those who
hadn't
found I love this so much please please
give me those pills give you confidence
huh is it wrong
of oh hey hey uh hey that's great uh can
you step out of vehicle for me please I
going to do a couple tests what's your
sign what's your
name is this really babar's
house look at that hair bro
Jesus his defense he's really not that
far off for the Mars VTA no cuz you know
this [__] too like doesn't cuz of the
psoriasis he probably just doesn't
shower as much he's probably like oh
bothers my skin it's like just a greasy
[__] makeup covered sweaty pill [__]
pilled up
mess I got you the link for the
song p it on a
respirator in a basement are they gone
all right uh you it you know Dayton
sounds like how somebody would sound if
they were singing a song but they were
dying yeah you know what I mean and they
didn't know the words like that's how I
imagine I would I would sound singing
Mars VTA if somebody shot me in the
stomach and I was just singing a song to
stay awake and not
die four this song is this one the one
py made four years ago it's been four
years yes all right let's go we'll teach
quick this also show you who Dayton is
this is an
update
God
God look at his [__] outfit what oh
his weird fingers
too I put on my favorite
dress in the bathroom I hide sasis on my
hands and legs I hear my brothering up
RP the chat time to film him from a
shadow corner
of this
house he beats me in this house this
house he beats me in this house feeling
hungry need to
eat oh no we're out of Health burritos
they're my favorite lunch treat father
offers to order
me my very own pizza but it's not from
where I li s remember that too house
remember he stole the credit card he
beats me in this house this
house he beats me in this this
house he beats me in this house this
house
[__] human
being [__]
FY I like how all the footage he has of
Sherman beating him too he never beats
him and it's always him harassing
Sherman and Sherman being like leave me
the [__]
alone oh my God
[Music]
fcking more like dating high pitch Nova
am I right hey
yo it's really good so you you put this
up and then like you like this is good
look at his eyes you're right people
need to see this you're right look at
his eyes he is Fu he's [__] gone
gone he's got a good falsetto but it's
his personality not his
voice
w w
[__] old neighborhood dogs going
crazy sings like a dog that knows he's
going I'm not hearing actual vocals on
this I'm nervous we are hearing the
vocals and trust me you're doing
yourself a
favor he sings like a dog that already
got neutered but they also accidentally
cut his dick
off hold on I think it's like a long
guitar solo yeah it's
Mars land craft C wheel of
scratches the tape worm his
pet I like that it's perfect because
he's not in tune he sounds terrible he's
not in in Rhythm to the song it's it's
perfect on every level is there any way
C can I can I this is like this is like
when Shifty show shell shock shows up to
do uh Crazy Town shows and they have to
do butterfly and he can't keep it
together for one song
now is there is there some way that we
could get Danny Saint to use this as his
entrance music okay is there any way we
can get Danny Saint to hit uh Dayton in
the face with a steel chair is there any
way you can make those things happen
both of those
things
please sorry best we can do is
f please
flin
and
forget
you think Sherman's glad he's dead I
mean I would be look at his bro he is
[__] gone oh yeah he's gone he is
gone wow the song I'm just skipping
ahead to see if he says something at the
end it's probably pretty
awful it was I don't know if I'm going
to like actually try to upload this and
listen but he did upload it and now it's
on my
computer so there's that uh you think
his family's just enabling him hoping
he'll just mix too much booze and benzo
one day I mean yeah hopefully like cuz I
would imagine there's got to be people
out there that like you just eventually
all decide look we're not getting in his
way let him let him let him do what he's
going to do cuz I I'm tired of
this